[Music]
I'm Hilde Lascaux and I'm a reporter
this is for the people who don't believe
in you
my dad's a reporter too
[Music]
you're back in town just got in you two
know each other it's been really nice
and quiet around here this is a warning
where are you been all day the crime
scene crime scene
Oh any left you died said he would never
move back here how come you're an 88 the
mayor's kid went missing they never
found out what happened to Richie is
that Dad my best friend it was taken I
want to see the police report from
Richie place can somewhat deal with this
I'm not going away I can't show you
everything so here's what I got ain't
helping I don't like when they Pat me on
the head either young lady you have no
idea what you're getting into if you're
like being called a young lady should be
a compliment but I never sounds like it
is what did you do I'm a journalist
you're a fourth grader there's a town
full of people that know more about my
husband than I do I think there's
something you should know
and heliacal school the interview murder
suspect
yeah well yes but no our family we work
out our problems together
[Music]
we're smart and rather be braised beef
balls
[Music]
you
you